je vous le disais au début de ce journal
mack cité vous propose ce soir une autre
vision de la prison à fresnes une partie
du bâtiment a été refait à neuf en bleu
couleur espoir il loge le centre
national d'observation tous les détenus
condamnés à plus de dix ans de prison
ils font un tour six semaines de tests
de dialogue avec des psychologues à la
sortie la plupart en rond une idée un
peu plus précise de ce que sera leur vie
en prison mais le séno peut-il vraiment
changer quelque chose à l'univers
carcéral pour en savoir plus l'équipe de
mac citer pascal ceaux et didier bonnet
ont suivi trois détenus ils ont accepté
de dire ce qu'il pensait tout ce qu'il
pensait mack cité
on a une population pénale qui est très
dangereuse qu'il ait enlevé ses deux
chevilles et les détruit
différemment
ici le travail des gardiens ne se limite
pas à la surveillance 24 heures sur 24
il observe les détenus et consignes
leurs remarques sur des carnets leurs
collègues du grand quartier les appelle
les éducateurs les psychologues nous
sommes une petite roulotte et autre
chose dont nous sommes surveillés donc
les observations tout simple sur le
comportement de chaque individu
il ya des détenus qui les font
des projets de l'exécution de peines
extraordinaire et puis lorsqu'on voit
que dans la cellule il ne lit jamais ils
regardent du matin au soir et de vision
ils restent couchés toute la journée il
est désiré désagréable il est agressif
ça nous permet de resituer la réalité de
du caractère de l'individu repas
café
[Musique]
pour venir au centre national
d'observation il faut être un détenu
comme andré avoir encore plus de dix ans
à purger
être comme francis dans la tente d'une
affectation centrale ou en centre de
détention
ou encore comme william ne pas savoir
quoi faire de toutes ces années derrière
les barreaux
six
jeux suivants
est ce que ça vous donne une impression
de quelque chose de surfer pendant leur
séjour au centre william et ses co
détenus sont convoqués plusieurs fois
pour des entretiens avec des
psychologues des psychiatres et des
éducatrices gens là ont passé les trois
ans cinq ans maison d'arrêt sans voir
personne et là on se retrouve pendant
six semaines avec des gens qui sont à
leur disposition qui vont les voir
plusieurs fois et là le travail devient
difficile non je n'ai rien à dire parce
que
je ne sais pas l'eau fonctions ils m'ont
dit mouvements dits fait quelque chose
moi je les fais c'est tout je finis avec
ses tares il est d'ailleurs du chichi
repos et voilà
jalome c'est toujours c'est toujours
important de dialoguer c'est toujours
important ça pour nous c'est
certainement cette voie d'eau dehors de
voir d'autres personnes mais c'est tout
de voir d'autres personnes mais ça
change pas le jeu
quatre semaines après leur arrivée andré
williams ne sont pas convaincus des
bienfaits du séno l'équipe d'observation
se heurte souvent à ce genre de
difficultés
comment aider un détenu a parlé de ce
crime comment le mettre en confiance
je crois que quand vous détenez
rencontre un être humain avec des tricks
du coeur et qu'il sent une certaine
humanité accueillant entaché l'autre il
y a un contact il ya une communication
qui peut s'établir et 7 justement
préserver cette chaleur humaine et dans
cet univers qui quand même un petit peu
froid
c'est un petit peu notre rôle moi j'ai
l'impression qu'elle est ce qu'elle sait
il est fou parce qu'il est fréquenté
tous les les gens malades watts et les
vinyles belle parce qu'elle est sécable
200 qui m'avait fait on a fait faire des
dessins éthique en king et après c'était
fini non rien du rebond j'ai passé trois
ans et qu'ils m'ont fait pareil
pour d'autres le centre national
d'observation est une chance une
parenthèse de six semaines dans la
prison ordinaire
valeur en termes de conflits on est là
en terme de population donc ça quand
même ça ça change des rapports humains
eux-mêmes les surveillants ici à l'amont
il ya une différence énorme avec la
deuxième division par exemple ici on
redevient pendant ces six semaines un
être humain à part entière le 6 on le si
c'était là qu'il fallait le mettre
d'accord
vous vous en souvenez un petit peu pas
vraiment voulu 200 savez c'est tellement
de brackley bafin donc ce sont des ce
sont vraiment des toutes petites erreurs
bref vous vous retrouvez une finalement
avec une avec une profession quelques
problèmes
ça constitue quand même hein
débauche d'énergie
un pour moi c'est un c'est important de
ses responsabilités et je pense que ça a
dû avoir une
parent
important dans ce tome
le règlement est pourtant le même que
dans les autres prisons la sécurité est
omniprésente pas une évasion en six ans
les condamnés les plus lourds de france
passe par le cn au pour l'administration
pénitentiaire
c'est un moyen d'évaluer leur
dangerosité un moyen d'aider le
ministère de la justice a décidé dans
quelle centrale les envoyer on essaie
d'associer en fait le détenu condamné à
une longue peine en fait à la gestion de
de sa détention c'est à dire de faire en
sorte que le temps qu'il a purgé en
détention les nombreuses années qu'il
aura à passer derrière les barreaux ne
soit pas en fait un temps mort un terme
entre parenthèses dans son existence
mais qu'il en sorte quelque chose de
positif
le positif prend souvent la forme d'une
reprise des études ou d'une formation
professionnelle le sait et nos organise
des tests de niveau
ce sont des textes qui existent
également à l'extérieur c'est à dire
qu'à partir du moment où il y a une
démarche en vue de le connaître un peu
plus l'individu en vue d'orienter ou ont
vu de lui donner ne serait ce que 1
point de vue
quant à l'emploi ou une qualification
une formation professionnelle nous nous
servions donc de ce genre d'outil
la mesure où on est en prison on a du
temps autant utiliser ce temps pour
préparer son futur sa réinsertion ça
fait un peu cliché mais mais mais c'est
vrai autant j'irai utile que gérer
bêtement la nuit
paisible
ena vivier quoi mettre des pains de
plusieurs comme ça c'est pas mon nom
bien cette nouvelle grille - n'a pas
senti match et voir personne je voyais
uniquement les sauver avant la bouffe on
al mabhouh fromager voie des bus et des
films à bleus
[Musique]
alors mais le poids la buvette en échec
tout sur scène il était fortement
encore
[Musique]
c'est pour les jeunes détenus comme
francis que le séjour et le plus
efficace mais tous n'ont qu'un souhait
purgé leur peine le plus près possible
de leur famille une bonne affectation
c'est ce qu'ils attendent du séno
si francis y croit dur comme fer andré
déjà venu ici en 76 se méfie de
l'ambiance bon enfant selon lui le
centre tente de faire oublier
l'essentiel rien d'occulté yeux par
exemple par l'art sexuelle en france en
fin d'année encore et ça c'est des trucs
c'est naturel ça les parloirs situation
existe c'est comme pour manger quand
vous mangez pas ce que vous avez faim
pour judy franchement c'est pas pour
acheminer tous les soirs je le touche eh
ben je me rende pas pigé demander pardon
conscient
je pense à
quatre ans derrière je compense à des
concerts ce que j'ai fait l'amour avec
soirée mais ça si je veux pas si c'est
tout ça que c'est rien
déjeuner du matin
il ennuie le café dans la tasse il a mis
le plus dans la tasse du café il a mis
le sucre dans le café au lait il
c'est
parti
120 par les
120 gardiens
et moi j'ai pris ma main dans ma tête et
j'ai pelé
s'est déjà pouvait
c'était avant
williams a appris à lire en prison cela
lui permettra peut-être de reprendre des
études en centrale cela figurera dans
son dossier c'est nous
l'original du dossier c'est nous en fait
suivra le détenu tout au long de ses
pérégrinations carcéral et sera en fait
un instrument de connaissance et de
travail mis à disposition des équipes de
détention qui rompt à gérer le détenu
dans les établissements dont tu fais
depuis 1950 le cn au a constitué plus de
30 mille dossiers pour chaque détenu six
semaines résumé en quelques pages de
synthèse
relate courriel
les dossiers de francis où liam et andré
sont parce que complet ils retourneront
bientôt attendre leur affectation à la
maison d'arrêt quand ce qu'ils appellent
l'enfer de la deuxième division c'est
assez angoissant dans le rhône c'est pas
le temps
pendant lequel on va rester si on disait
voilà a priori vous devriez rester de
vous prendre waouh quel con on peut se
faire une idée on peut se dire beau mais
là c'est complètement c'est l'inconnu on
peut très bien rester deux mois rester
six mois restait huit mois certains même
quelques rares cas restent plus
longtemps que ça
[Musique]
enfin terminée par trois lots fait
si on n'a rien on vous a encore besoin
j'ai vu beaucoup de gens crever
opposants j'ai vu des amis viennent faut
aussi
même des mois aussi parce que l'occident
vers 600 g dans le petit musée leurs
conseils j'ai fait des choses
pour mon genre 2016 15 ou oui je vous
dise
qu'est ce que je vais faire que je vais
sortir je sais pas quand je vais sortir
je ne peux pas vous qu'on peut pas avoir
de moi je vois je connais personne qui
je parle de beaucoup de gens je parle il
me dit il qu'à 20 ans ou 15 ans à faire
il me dit quand juste sortir je veux
faire ça c'est impossible et je vous
pose la question dans 15 ans
qu'est ce que vous pensez vert
[Musique]